i'm curious i mean especially storm and
nika you guys
don't have an intervention moment or
scene this season you have a whole
intervention episode
incredible work from both of you on that
but it's exhausting mentally and
emotionally to watch
so what was it like to shoot what is
essentially you know an episode long
intervention
yeah it's like you just mentioned
emotionally exhausting
you you don't realize okay i have my
lines i i know what i'm going to do but
after a while your body is is affected
in a way that i i wasn't ready for i
mean there's a lot of
running after each other and and and and
and tackling and and and and holding and
you know and so
you you forget there's emotional and
physical
um you know exhaustion and it was like i
was happy when it was over i was just
like whoa okay i had to go home i had to
decompress it was it was a lot but i
think it's it's what was needed
um for this season because i think
rue's character needs to understand that
it's not just her younger sister gia
being affected it's
her whole sphere of
people in her life her tribe you know
and to see everyone come together and
really root for her to get better i
think i think that's what
i don't know if that's going to get her
clean but i think that's definitely
something that um the audience needs to
know like she she does have support
everywhere she turns there's someone
supporting her
yeah
what was that like for you because i
mean do you prepare for something like
that do you try not to prepare going it
like how do you work that out so that
you get through that um well i think my
process is with anything but
specifically euphoria and
being gia i think it is to prepare but
not
over prepare because things always are
changing and there's always new ideas
and and and opportunities in which we
find something that really works so that
is really brilliant in the moment um but
i mean i i think everything miss nika
said it it's exhausting doing those
scenes it's literally
physically emotionally and mentally
exhausting and i feel so privileged and
so blessed to be able to
work on scenes or
work on scenes like that when i'm doing
them because that's what i want as an
actress is to be challenged to be pushed
to feel like i just i don't want to do
this anymore i can't do it anymore i
feel like that's where my best work
comes from but
i i would say it is it's it's hard and i
would go back to campus and and go back
to school after i was done filming those
scenes and i would just be done for it
so it paid off but it was it was hard
coleman things get a bit rocky between
your character and rue this season which
is to be expected when you're dealing
with an addict what was it like for you
to explore
that portion of their dynamic and and to
also
you know have her
come to some sort of realization that
she needs to apologize for her behavior
you know as i think about it now
in the playing of it it was very
interesting
to me that
even ali is shocked at the level
of how
horrible uh
that an addict can be
to shock someone like ali who's been it
who's done it who's done plenty of it to
be shocked yet again by someone who can
actually you made a bond with you've
poured your heart open to each other you
were there for each other in that you
know the trouble don't last always
episode you really unpack so much and
have this bond
and then to break that bond i think it
just really shocked him and so
immediately that's why we made the
choice that ali just grabs because of
his impulse
and then he shocked at what she brought
out in him as well
like she knew how to push his buttons it
keeps letting you know how um
unsettling and how stable the disease of
addiction is and how people will they
will do anything
to
have things go their way the whole
season she's
manipulative as hell
you know but she's using everything
she's using at some point she uses i
think my perspective i think sometimes
she uses the death of her father to give
us to get sympathy which is like you
will even use that
so i think that
i think ali understanding the disease of
addiction and his whole purpose and his
whole engine in the scene is to sort of
be that um
that uh north star
to say i've been through it i've been
through the worst i've done it i've you
know impossibly to offer up some light
that things can get better you can do
something different with your family you
can do something different with school
um i don't know if he's saying to do it
he's just offering up you know what he
knows so i think that um yeah i think it
is it is wild the ark that they have and
i think it's an arc that is built on
trying to be built on just honesty
and um
and faith
but then when you know the disease of
addiction is in the middle of it it's in
between two addicts he understands it so
he can find some um some grace he can
find a moment to say um of redemption
because he he would like that in the
world too i think that's why i really
loved the moments between them when they
have this dinner and they've all come
together and they share moments either
you know preparing the food or just
sitting there because it's really sort
of the only time that there isn't chaos
happening this season
so what was it like to have those
moments in contrast to
you know doing something like the
intervention episode to then have
a moment just at the dinner table
that's that's the happier side of
euphoria that's the real euphoria you
know everyone's around the table eating
a meal you know cracking jokes being
lighthearted having fun i i think you
know for us
well let me just speak for myself
those were some of the the the memories
that i will always have you know as an
actor us literally like being together
at that table
joking singing having fun but then in
the scene there's definitely the
undertone of like the reality of
what what's happening and and so it's
it's a it's a little form of escapism i
think
we're allowed to escape just just for so
just for a moment to make it to make it
feel like wow this this is normal this
is the thing we thought that right right
after you guys like maybe like within
that week am i right after you guys had
that
because i remember sam kept saying to me
oh man you should have seen that scene
but they the work that they did and like
so this is so i guess you guys came into
the scene as well just like oh i need
some light i need some fun and laughter
because
everybody was chatting we were talking
we're laughing we and we also
before the scene even starts we improv a
little bit just to like warm it up
telling jokes and stories and everyone
is on it and just having fun so i think
um
i think it was well i personally think
it was well earned for these two and
with rue because i know that they went
through hell just day before so i'm i'm
just happy to be there be in the room
and be a little light
bravo all of you on the work on that you
all broke my heart this season so thank
you for talking to me about it
thank you